welcome to this video orgasm orgasm yep
and from Sweden Sweden and we have a
trump good old Trump offski you know I
have transposed to the London system
basically in a very yeah inoffensive way
let's say for white very very equal
already this position okay but if I go
here I mean how is white supporting this
night should g5 is not leading a Bishop
b5 I mean it's not leading to to
anything okay let's let's see can I try
to play for an edge yeah with this with
his somewhat weird configuration 94 this
was something that I was thinking of I
wanted to weaken weaken this now f6 he's
got what 93 93 if five not sure g5 not
don't like that okay let's just push him
back it should be okay at least now if I
have right
u5 it's this like just it's just just
not so great
like it looks active but maybe it's not
that great sometimes yeah but it is okay
it's okay
he will go back to h2 or something yeah
okay I know he takes oh wow this I
didn't expect
I didn't expect him to to open the the
position for me okay is the idea to play
c4 I am that that is a possible possible
nuisance I would like to play the night
back and play E for I am to get the
night back there maybe just back to f6
and then if Roya see for FY that's okay
that's okay Mia what if I would have
played C for his night does not have had
it wouldn't have had many squares yes
and would have been interesting okay
it's not lose too much sleep about it
and continue here it is still not bad at
all mostly because the night has no good
square form that may be a form yeah I
still play D for him I push I push this
yeah here I guess first the Queen in the
middle and then d4 he has to play an
awkward move to cover the knight or move
that yes okay let's push the whole thing
yeah Queen a5 is probably his idea and
what I need is an attack me I needed a
ticket going but how I need to look look
on the six rank or something or do I
just play the pawn up and Knight to g7
and to cover the whole business
they're not easy
you know that that's something that
needs precision but I'm not really sure
how to how to do it okay I didn't want
to play that but maybe I need you
yeah the situation is not clear to me
not not at all there is some I mean this
is a strong poll on d3 and it's not
clear that his pieces are so well placed
okay you will probably go back there I
need I need some h5 maybe do that
anticipating porn moves I want to play
rook f6 g6 and stuff like that and they
needed them a secure back rank there's
also the idea really Wow
okay I'm going to take it's not I mean
if it takes 90 X I'm just in good shape
even with Queens off
so now let's let's go over there look to
look to g6 bring out the heavy artillery
here and when the queen is coming to g5
there is 95 and if the knight joins the
whole thing then white is going to be
checkmated this is this is really really
happening
I'm sure okay look here yeah there is no
queen bee 897 zoom Queen g5 hi Marty
yeah I am Queen g5 still and then 95
okay hard hard to blame f2 is hanging
it's not protecting that okay knight on
e4 oops
okay maybe maybe I
how to have the same as chick it's a
shame I cannot play Knight f3 okay I'm
going to do that now that that is I
really have no no big choice ping and
Ruby six coming
therefore maybe which is six Queen age
three I take it with the pawn I have
actually - I don't have root G - no I
don't have that if I go D - I'm
threatening Knight d3 checkmate almost
made can go to the G file yeah I don't
know I just needed to move that was an
IG for was winning the Queen as well
okay at least not on this time I can
think for a moment that since don't
really see how we can defend this stuff
white resigns resigns maybe talked
really no 9300 looks it looks white is
probably lost but resigns is still a bit
a bit surprising well I really have no
idea I mean I definitely think that I
should have compensation here and in
some form but I don't really know if it
is good for me or whatever the computer
says black is better but I don't I don't
really know it takes takes and now it
wants to go d5 here with the pawns okay
g5 g4 with the clutch but this also
seems to be good Queen g5 yes okay seven
rook F seven was stronger here I had
this also is good okay and now King age
seven okay clearing the King with black
winning and it is probably a winning
attack but I couldn't I couldn't really
really figure it out
and worked you to win sway so my
intuition was right there to just smash
them
but the winners queen g5 Andrew f3 Wow
okay Jack okay King h1 Ruka free this is
the real win and what I didn't see at
all is that if you go CLS this is the
queen witness in them yeah but what I
did is actually still winning and there
were easier things d2 is the best one
funny even better than this
but I was just average dis - you know
whose and hoping that it would work I
mean it's clear that this is a strong
attack but I couldn't calculate anything
here okay Wow thanks for watching